for 2023s weak growth forecasts for the
global economy wheat growth forecast for
the UK too
six months ago that the UK was one of
the big talking topics here in
Washington after the mini budget and
what was happening in the guilts market
I just wonder you know six months on how
is the UK doing right now there is a
higher dependence on on uh on imported
energy that it's a fairly uh tight labor
market and so there's been a need for a
fairly aggressive tightening of monetary
policy and and there is some effect
there's some already some signs of the
transmission of this monetary policy to
the to the Border economy but Britain's
problems are dwarfed by those echoing
around the world with each new height
and interest rates the financial system
creaks dangerously with uh tightening of
policy and slowing economic activity of
course there is going to be stress for
the moment we have seen more stress more
stress than in previous years perhaps oh
absolutely so we have seen losses due to
Rising interest rates as the value of
Securities have gone down but we could
also see credit losses at some time
one thing I can tell you for sure about
this economic forecast is that they will
end up being wrong that's kind of the
nature of economic forecasts far more
important is to look at the mood music
and here well the fact that the IMF is
talking about words like perilous and
ominous gives you a sense of just how
nervous they are they think there could
be more explosions yet to come
risks are very much tilted to the
downside that balance that has to be
struck between getting inflation down
achieving price stability and monetary
authorities are doing what they feel
they need to do in in that issue and but
also ensuring that we protect Financial
stability the good news for Jeremy Hunt
will be in town later this week is the
expectations for Britain are low the
last time a Chancellor came here he left
early to be fired for Britain and its
economic growth prospects the only way
is up
at Conway Sky News in Washington